ROMAN NURIK: Hello, and welcome
again to "Android
Design in Action." I'm your
host, Roman Nurik.
ADAM KOCH: Hey guys, my
name's Adam Koch.
NICK BUTCHER: And hi,
I'm Nick Butcher.
ROMAN NURIK: And today, we have
a special episode, once
again, on home screen widgets.
We're going to take a look at
a couple of home screen
widgets at the very end.
A couple of home screen
widgets that we
think do a good job.
But first, we're going to talk
about designing home screen
widgets, how you should approach
them in general.
We're going to talk about some
design guidelines for widgets,
and then talk about some of the
constraints, since as a
designer, you may not be fully
aware of the different types
of things you can and can't do
with home screen widgets.
So with that, should we
just jump right in?
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, let's do it.
ROMAN NURIK: All right.
OK, so what is a home
screen widget?
Well, according to the
design guidelines--
the link down there
is at the bottom.
So, "Widgets are an essential
aspect of the home screen
customization.
You can imagine them as
at-a-glance views of an app's
most important data and
functionality." I'd actually
add latest data, as well here,
since it's very important that
widgets are up to date.
And it's "accessible right from
the user's home screen.
Users can move widgets across
their home screen panels, and,
if supported, resize them."
So that's another important
aspect is the customizability,
the fact that you can basically
take a widget, move
it wherever you want and to
whichever home screen you
want, resize it to fit whatever
icons are around it.
And it's really there
to make it your own.
So that's a home screen widget
at a very high-level overview.
The idea is that you basically
take a part of your app and
throw it onto the home screen.
NICK BUTCHER: And I think--
just want to interject-- it's
one of the uniquely Android
features that I love to
see in an application.
You can't get much more prime
real estate than owning a
small piece of the user's
home screen.
This is where most of their
user journeys are going to
start from.
I know personally, on the
bus, you're bored.
You're just clicking around
your phone, seeing
what's going on.
I love to be able to see
the latest information.
It's similar to the rules, which
Alex went through last
week, about notifications but
without that kind of pressing
time sensitivity or a person
waiting for it.
It's the latest information that
the user has opted in and
requested to be notified about
is kind of brought and
surfaced to the user.
And it's such a great
opportunity.
It's such a shame when an
application with this kind of
information doesn't take
advantage, I think, of the
home screen widget.
ROMAN NURIK: And I'd say
that there are certain
users that if they--
or actually, I guess if you add
a home screen widget, it's
probably a pretty strong signal
that you're pretty
passionate about the app.
So some of your biggest power
users will be the ones that
use the home screen widget.
Not everybody will use it.
Not everybody decides to add
it to their home screen.
But the folks that do really
probably love your content.
So let's move on.
So there are a few types
of home screen widgets.
So if you look at the
design guidelines,
they'll talk about these.
But they're roughly broken up
into three main categories--
information-type widget, like
weather, that shows you
information at a glance.
Control widgets that let you
make changes to a certain app,
or even the system,
in this case.
And collection widgets, which
basically let you see
collections of data scrolling
vertically to see past items
or other items in the list.
And then, of course, there's the
hybrid type of widget that
includes multiple items.
And most widgets are probably
going to be
kind of hybrid widgets.
They'll include aspects of
showing information, also
allowing you access to control
of the app, or potentially
linking you into different parts
of the app, which we'll
talk about in a bit.
And so there are a couple things
that I think make a
home screen widget really
good, a couple of key
important items.
So the first is up-to-date.
A home screen widget
should be dynamic.
It should never really be just
showing one piece of
information from a week
ago or two weeks ago.
It should really be something
that the user would open up
their home screen and expect to
see the latest and greatest
information.
So for example, if you have, for
some reason, a widget that
does traffic, then you should
probably show something that's
very immediate, something
that's relevant to
the next few hours.
If you have a widget that's
showing weather, also you want
to show something that's
kind of around now.
You don't want to show weather
from yesterday or
something like that.
As well as news articles or
Gmail or any sort of list or
feed-type widget, you want to
make sure to basically update
the widget as soon as
there's new data.
So for example, in the case of
Gmail, when you get a new
email, there's a push message
that's sent to the device that
basically tells the Gmail
application that, hey, there's
a new email.
So along with updating the
cached content for Gmail, you
should also make sure to trigger
an update to the
widget so that the widget can
show that new information.
And this is all possible.
As a developer, you could
do this, of course.
But as a designer, you should
plan for push updates to your
widget as the information
comes in.
You can also specify
a periodic refresh.
And absolutely, most widgets
should probably refresh
automatically, unless there's
some great reason not to.
And generally, you don't want to
refresh too often, like for
example, refreshing once a
minute, or once every few
minutes, even.
That's pretty dangerous,
because you may suck up
battery life.
And basically, you should
probably optimize around
refreshes of no more frequent
than, say, once every half
hour to an hour.
That's probably the peak or the
minimum refresh time for a
widget without using too
much battery life.
The other thing to note is that
there's a lot of ways to
tweak this, but you
should also be
conscious of when you update.
So do you actually want to
update when the phone is
sleeping, or do you want
to update only when
the phone is awake?
And those are things that as a
developer, you can control.
But as a designer, you should
also be aware of the different
types of updates you
can do for widgets.
The other very important thing
about a widget is that it
should be actionable.
So it's one thing to just
show information.
But generally, the information
you show is a snippet, right?
So you don't actually
just want to end
the experience there.
You want to somehow let
the user dive deeper.
If they actually care about
the news story that you're
showing, for example, in your
widget, let them touch on that
story and jump into the details
for that so that they
can read it.
NICK BUTCHER: It could also be
like a teaser, almost, think
like a newspaper headline,
right?
So you want to be able to tease
these and entice them to
click through to more details.
ROMAN NURIK: Absolutely.
And another thing to point out--
and Nick, you'll talk
about this later-- but it's
important to note that widgets
can have different
linkable regions.
So make sure to be aware of what
are the different types
of things a user would want to
do from this widget, and
tailor to those different
behaviors.
The other thing is that a widget
should be very, very
customizable.
So again, the idea is that
a user is granting their
precious real estate
to you, right?
They're giving away part of
their home screen to you, so
you should make sure to make
your widget as customizable as
you feel is fit in the
sense that make
sure that is resizable.
One of the worst things is when
a user finds a widget
that can't be resized,
or is too large.
And then it's requesting
too much of that
precious real estate.
So make sure that you design
your widget to scale to
different sizes.
The other thing is that you
generally want to show
information that's custom
tailored to the user.
So for example, if it's like a
reader-type thing or a feed
consumption app, and the user
has a list of favorite feeds
that you want to see,
make sure to make
that a default option.
But let them, obviously,
customize if they want to
change things around.
And then also note that there
is the option of a
configuration step.
So after the user selects which
widget to add, you have
the option of providing kind of
an interstitial page where
they can customize what should
be shown in the widget.
So make sure to make use
of that as well.
So again, in the case of the
feed reader example, you want
to give them the option to
specify which feeds they'd
like to see in that widget.
NICK BUTCHER: And that's
probably preferable to having
multiple widgets, even though
the application can, rather
than having 10, 15 different
widgets or all the different
feeds your application might
be able to produce, it's
preferable to probably have
just the one and a
configuration step.
ROMAN NURIK: Right.
And so in past versions of
Android, you weren't able to
create resizable widgets.
So one of the biggest
workarounds was, let's just
create four different widgets
of four different sizes.
On newer versions of the
platform, you should hide away
all those widgets.
You should only really
show the single
widget that is resizable.
That's the best approach.
So let's move on and talk
about the guidelines.
Nick, do you want to
kick us off here?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, so speaking
of sizing, the way
that the widget system works is
you have a number of cells
on your home screen.
So one cell is typically
the size of
an application shortcut.
And so when you're designing
your widget, you want to be
cognizant of when your users
place the widget on the home
screen, they're going to
allocate it a number of cells.
So hopefully, you're using
a resizable widget.
What you would do is you'd set
the minimum number of cells
which make sense for the
information you're going to
present, and then let the
user resize it by
the number of cells.
So when you come to actually
designing that, you need to
think about a few things.
The first thing is that these
cells aren't really that
deterministic.
There's a slight amount of
flexibility in the actual
size, depending on the device
implementation.
So the home screen is in
landscape or portrait, the
actual number of pixels may vary
slightly, so you need to
build a lot of flexibility into
your widget, really, so
it can cope with a little bit
of change either way of the
ideal boundary sizes.
And also, it's worth bearing in
mind that the actual pixel
size and the way that we handle
margins has changed
slightly in the newer
versions of Android.
So previously, we used to leave
it up to the developer
to include any padding
inside the bounds.
So we would just give them the
cell and let them draw
anywhere they liked within it
and would hope that they would
include sensible amounts
of paddings.
We decided to change that in
Android 4.0, primarily to help
keep the home screens slightly
more aligned so that everyone
was using similar [INAUDIBLE]
of the same paddings so that
everything was on a
nice, tight grid.
So you need to be
aware of that.
So we've included here the
formula which we used to
calculate the size of the
cells in DP units.
So bear these in mind when
you're creating widgets.
If you're targeting just 4.0 and
above, you might want to
use one formula.
If you want to target older
devices, then you need to bear
in mind how much padding
to allow for.
ROMAN NURIK: One other thing I
wanted to add is that this is
a good guideline to follow
for minimum sizes.
But note that the widget
may actually grow.
So for example, on a tablet,
let's say, the home screen, if
you rotate the device from
landscape to portrait, the
cells aren't actually still
perfectly square.
They're actually
never perfectly
square, as far as I know.
The idea is that in landscape,
the cells are slightly wider.
And in portrait, the cells
are slightly taller.
So designing with this formula
in mind will give you a good
minimum size.
But note that it can grow and
shrink based on different
orientations, as well as
different devices.
Different devices have slightly
different cell sizes.
But this is a very
good guideline.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, we'll get
more into the layout controls
that you can actually
use in your app.
But basically, yeah, bear that
in mind in thinking in terms
of scaling layouts, and how
they're going to stretch and
fill these differently
sized cells.
ROMAN NURIK: So let's
move on to the next
slide around styling.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, so styling
is very important.
I think we touched on it earlier
when we were talking
about you're occupying--
the user's giving you a
small amount of space
on their home screen.
So you really need to fit it in
with the rest of the home
screen and the other
apps on there.
So for that reason, you really
want to be fitting in with the
rest of the platforms.
And following the Holo styling
guidelines is a great start to
fit in with what other widgets
are going to look like on the
home screen, as well as the
standard visual style of the
app shortcuts and so on.
We found that subtle
transparency works really well
here, because the
user has chosen
their personal wallpaper.
And so to work nicely with
that and to go with their
color scheme, we find that
transparency can work quite
well there.
It aligns, also, to the
system widgets, how
we do that as well.
ROMAN NURIK: Just one point
I wanted to point out.
So a lot of these system widgets
actually have subtle
transparency.
It's not showing up well
here in the slides.
But the idea is that in very,
very small parts of the
widget, you'll see a
little bit of the
background peek through.
And it kind of gives that extra
feeling of digital.
It's a real object, but it's
actually something that's
living in my digital world.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, exactly.
And I think the users chose
the background on purpose.
You feel a sense of ownership
with that--
connection with that.
And I think it reinforces the
fact that you're on the user's
home screen.
They've chosen to give you this
piece of space as well,
that you blend in well with it,
literally, by using these
design principles.
And the last thing I wanted to
pull out here is that even
though you are not in the full
app mode, you want to be doing
all the good practices, like
including pressed state or
inactive states for all your
elements, because they are
still interactive elements,
and they still need
to respond to touch.
ROMAN NURIK: The other thing
about pressed states is that
since, again, you're on the
user's home screen, where
generally the pressed states
are using a blue glow, for
example, for icons, or for
different widgets, they're
probably using that kind of
semi-transparent blue overlay.
You want to use a similar
pressed state, if possible, if
it fits in with your theme.
Because again, we generally want
the home screen to feel
like a single, unified
experience.
And as much as widgets can do
to fall in place and just be
cohesive with the rest of the
launcher, that's very important.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, just as your
job when you're building
an app is to marry your brand's
visual style with the
Android visual style, this is
all the more leaning towards
the default Android visual
style on the home screen,
because you're going to be
shoulder to shoulder with
other players, as it were.
ADAM KOCH: Personally, if the
styling and the padding are
off for a particular widget, I'm
probably going to remove
it from my home screen.
It just doesn't fit in with the
flow of the home screen.
So I think this slide and the
previous slide are very
important to consider.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, home screens
are precious things.
ADAM KOCH: Very precious.
Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: There's whole
communities of people just
around sharing images
of how they
configure their home screen.
People get very passionate
about this stuff, so
[? we're being ?]
very respectful.
ROMAN NURIK: It's something
you see--
I don't know about a
few hundred times a
day, but you see--
ADAM KOCH: Possibly 100 times.
ROMAN NURIK: Possibly, yeah,
100 times a day.
So you want to make it as
beautiful as possible.
NICK BUTCHER: And then the
next step is a personal
bugbear of mine, which is
applications which don't
provide a preview image.
So you can provide one preview
image for a widget.
And this is used not only
in the tray here--
so when I'm going through and
selecting a widget, I go into
the widget tray and then long
press [INAUDIBLE] to pick it
up and then place it
on my home screen.
But also, when I'm placing it,
a slightly semi-transparent
version will be--
I'll hold onto it and hover it
to place it where I want on
the home screen.
So it's really important to
include this visual image of
what the widget's going
to look like.
When they're placed into the
tray, you'll be aware that you
have this landscape cropped
representation.
So if you provide a very tall
widget, it's going to do a
center-top crop.
So if you look in this example
we're showing here of the
Photo Gallery widget, it's
showing the top half, almost,
of the preview image,
which is fine.
But just bear that in mind
when you're designing the
asset, that it may be
displayed as such.
And then when I pick it up to
place it on the home screen,
it will display the whole
image in this kind of
semi-transparent way.
And also, when you're creating
this, you want to be cognizant
not to be leaking any personal
data or anything like that.
You want to create these with
test data just when you're
designing them.
ROMAN NURIK: And one general
technique that I've used when
creating widgets is
basically take a
screen shot of the widget.
Open it up in Photoshop.
And I'm guessing that as a
designer, you probably have
some of the source
assets, anyway.
But drop in the source assets
on top of your screen shot,
line things up appropriately,
and then just replace all the
real data with dummy data.
And then export that as a PNG
file and drop it in as a
preview image.
The other thing to note about
preview images is that you
should try to avoid showing any
extra transparent pixels
around the sides of the preview
image since the
launcher will automatically
apply padding and margins so
that your preview image
isn't flush with the
bounds of its cell.
Should we move on?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah,
absolutely.
ROMAN NURIK: All right.
NICK BUTCHER: And this is
a few more guidelines.
We touched briefly on the
configuration, but this is an
example of what it
might look like.
So if you drop the
Google Play--
the Library widget, which shows
you all your books and
movies you've been
watching lately--
you'll get this dialogue, which
will pop up offering you
if you want to personalize it,
just one of the media sources.
So some general guidelines
about creating these
configuration steps is you want
to keep it very light.
You do want to make it
personalizable, but you don't
want to be leading the user
through five, six, seven deep
series of steps.
This is supposed to quite
a light process to grab
something and place it
onto the home screen.
So do keep that in mind.
The other thing is we do
recommend to use a dialogue
style here.
This is one of the very few
cases, I guess, where we
recommend a dialogue, just to
keep the user in the context,
that you are actually working
on something on the home
screen, and you're not deep in
the app [INAUDIBLE] where they
were coming from.
ROMAN NURIK: Absolutely.
Moving on to the linking.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
NICK BUTCHER: --go a little
bit deeper about linking
through to content.
So as we talked about earlier,
it's all about another avenue
to expose your content.
So you want to be having items
of content-- so here, this
email widget, individual
emails.
There might be individual
news stories.
And they want to be deep
links straight
through to that content.
This isn't just a
launcher widget.
They want to be able to have
the avenues go straight to
read more about it.
But you also want to include
access points, other common
points in your application the
user might want to get to.
So typically, we see that as
being the top level of the
application.
And quite often, you'll use your
app icon in the top left
[INAUDIBLE]
pattern as a quick access to the
root of the application.
So that means the user doesn't
have to have-- if you didn't
have this, you might have those
deep links through to
the emails, but then you
might also have to
have an email shortcut.
You want to remove that.
The user's going all
out and putting a
widget on the home screen.
They don't want to have
a shortcut to the
application as well.
It's kind of one or the other.
So give them a way to get to the
top level of the app, as
well as to come [INAUDIBLE], in
the email example, again,
creating a new email
is an example here.
And it might be taking a photo
or whatever it might be.
And just a little note there,
mostly for those developers
out there, really, is that our
recommendations on navigation
is that if you do deep link
into the application, you
should be synthesizing
[INAUDIBLE].
ROMAN NURIK: All right, let's
move on to the lock screen,
one of my favorite parts of
the widget framework.
NICK BUTCHER: Yes, so one of
the new, shiny features in
Android 4.2 is the ability to
place widgets not only on the
home screen but on
the lock screen.
And talk about immediate
info and control.
You don't get much more
immediate than that.
This is like zero interaction
information.
You just have to turn
the phone on,
and that's it, right?
You don't even have
to unlock it.
So some things to be aware of is
that we allow slightly less
personalization options
on the lock screen.
Widgets essentially
run in two sizes.
So you can see on the slide here
there's an example of the
calendar widget.
So either you have the ability
to unlock-- so that could be
the slide unlock or some kind
of secure PIN, in which case
the widget is in a collapsed
state-- or it takes up the
whole screen.
There's no in-between state.
ROMAN NURIK: There's another
thing to note on that is that
you actually can have multiple
widgets on a lock screen.
This is just an example
of one.
But as of Android 4.2, you
can actually add more
items to the left.
Or I believe they're actually
all to the left.
To the right, there's
the camera.
But to the left, you can
add other items.
So where the center widget,
where the first thing you see
when you unlock, or when you
press the power button, the
first thing you see
may be the clock.
If you swipe to the
left, you can
actually add widgets there.
And those will always
be expanded.
The other thing I want to--
NICK BUTCHER: You can see, if
you look at the back screen
shot, the expanded calendar
view, you can see there's an
extra panel peeking
in to the side.
Don't know if you can make that
out in the screenshot.
But yeah, you can swipe
across the other ones.
ROMAN NURIK: The other thing
to note is that on tablets,
there is no collapsed view.
There is just expanded view.
This is kind of the current
presentation of things.
These things may change
in the future.
And certainly, I don't think
we have guidance on
third-party devices or other
OEMs, how they would present
lock screen widgets.
There's certainly lots
of different options.
But the core API, you should
assume that there'll be a
collapsed and expanded state
and in some cases, no
collapsed state.
NICK BUTCHER: And speaking of
the current presentation right
now, we darkened the
wallpaper slightly.
I think it's about
40% [INAUDIBLE].
ROMAN NURIK: Something
like that.
NICK BUTCHER: Something
I forget exactly.
So all of the stock controls,
like to actually go ahead and
unlock the devices,
are in monochrome
white on top of that.
And that contrasts well, because
obviously, the user
can control what the wallpaper
is behind.
So yeah, using white as the main
color in your design will
work well here, because
[INAUDIBLE] at the moment
guaranteed to contrast.
ADAM KOCH: One quick note on the
development side is this
is just really one extra XML
attribute that you need to add
to make your widget compatible
with both the home screen and
the lock screen.
But obviously, not all home
screen widgets should be
placed or should be allowed to
be placed on the lock screen.
It really comes down to the
application and the
information you're trying
to display.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
And by the way, when you add a
lock screen widget, you do,
again, have the option
of providing a
configuration step.
You may want to ask the user,
what are you comfortable
showing on the lock screen?
Do you want to show all the
information, or maybe just a
snippet of information that
doesn't include personal
information or contact
information from other people?
But definitely keep in mind that
there's this extra place
here where you potentially
have insecure
access to the device.
Somebody can just walk by the
user's cubicle, see their
phone, and if this is a bad
person, they can take a look
at the phone.
If they don't know the pattern,
they'll still be able
to access the lock
screen widgets.
So if those have insecure
information, that's a problem.
NICK BUTCHER: So I'm probably
not going to put my bank
account balance onto a
lock screen widget.
But something like a to-do list,
like one of my favorite
to-do lists that I use lets me
do a lock screen widget.
So I'm shopping, I'm walking
around the shops, I don't even
have to unlock my device to
tick things off as I walk
around the aisles, place
them in my basket.
I can just literally
turn the screen on,
tick, tick, tick, done.
It's great.
ROMAN NURIK: Awesome.
NICK BUTCHER: OK.
Constraints.
ROMAN NURIK: Oh, actually,
there's one more thing I
wanted to mention.
When you actually touch an item
on a lock screen widget--
like let's say you were
to touch, I guess,
this calendar item--
you'd actually be given the
option first to unlock.
If you don't unlock the device,
it'll actually just
cancel that click.
So keep in mind that what's
on the widget is insecure.
But once you touch on something,
it will be secure.
So constraints.
Should I talk about
constraints?
So there are a couple
constraints that you should
keep in mind when you're
designing home screen widgets.
The first is there isn't really
support for custom fonts.
So from a developer's
standpoint, in your app, you
can actually just specify a font
file, a TrueType file to
use for a given view, like a
label or a piece of edit text
or something like that.
But on widgets, there's no
real way to do that.
There is a hack.
You can obviously render the
text into a bitmap, into an
image, and throw that
into the widget.
But that's just a really,
really bad hack.
It's very bad for performance,
things like that.
So just avoid custom
fonts, if possible.
There's also no opportunity
for custom animations.
This is something that a few
designers have asked me.
What can I really do?
Can I make cool transitions--
when I press one thing,
the widget rotates?
Unfortunately, the widget
framework right now is a
little static.
So if you touch on something in
the widget, you can update
the widget.
You can change the contents,
show something expand or
whatnot, but you won't be able
to animate it really well.
So just kind of assume that
there won't be animations.
One thing to note is that if
you're touching an item and
jumping into the full screen
view, like deep linking into
content, as of Android 4.1,
there is something called
Activity Options where you can
basically create a zoom-up
animation from the content.
But that's basically the limit
of the animation abilities you
can do with widgets.
Actually, there's also
the option of
cross-fading between views.
We'll talk about that
in a second.
Also, there's no horizontal
gesture support.
So the main way you navigate the
home screen and the lock
screen is you swipe left and
right to change between your
different screens.
Since that's a very important
gesture, we don't allow
widgets to contain
views that can
horizontally scroll as well.
So the only type of scrolling
or flinging or anything like
that you can do is vertical.
And to do that, you need to use
one of the specific views,
which we'll talk about.
Also, vertical scrolling
is only available
as of Android 3.0.
Resizability, basically the
ability to long press on the
widget and then get those nice
little resize handles, is only
in Android 3.1.
And then we added this option
to change the layout of your
widget, based on its
size dynamically.
And so basically, after you
resize, you can update the
layout of the widget.
And that was added in Jellybean,
Android 4.1.
So in earlier versions, you're
basically stuck with your
layout once you've placed it,
and even after you resized it,
until the next time
you updated it.
ADAM KOCH: I think we
mentioned this.
Lock screen widgets
are 4.2+ as well.
ROMAN NURIK: Right.
So those are some of
the constraints.
The other thing to keep in mind
is that there are certain
things you just can't
do in widgets.
For example, you can't play
video in widgets.
You can't play a game
in a widget.
You can't draw arbitrary
stuff into the widget.
There are a few standard things
that you can do, though.
The common things, like text
labels and images and buttons,
those work.
There's support for loading
spinners as well, progress
bars as well.
Although, like we mentioned
before, you don't want to
update the widget very,
very frequently.
So it's not really feasible to
have a progress bar that
updates as you're downloading
something, for example.
So progress bars, you should
probably only use for percent
watched, for example.
If the widget is showing the
latest TV show episode that
I've seen, and I've seen 50%
of it, maybe you can use a
progress bar to show that
I've seen 50% of it.
But don't show something that
is supposed to update very,
very frequently.
You can also show an
in-place carousel.
Basically, you have an image
in place in the widget, and
then after a few seconds,
it kind of fades out
into another image.
You can do something
like that.
A good example of that is the
news and weather widget that
comes by default with Nexus
4, things like that.
And that's an alternative to
a collection widget that
basically lets you scroll
up and down.
And then you can add some
clocks in there
if you really want.
Also for scrollable elements,
you can have list views.
And by list view, I don't mean
specifically, basically, a
view containing a list item or
a piece of text followed by
another piece of text.
Your list items themselves,
the items you show in this
list view, can be
fairly complex.
You can do lots of different
things in them.
So don't treat this
as a list view.
Think of it more as a basic kind
of collection view that
can list items or different
presentations.
NICK BUTCHER: The email and
calendar examples, I guess we
showed briefly earlier, are good
examples of that, where
you can show quite a lot of
different [INAUDIBLE] content
in that list view and have
a user click through it.
ROMAN NURIK: And also, you
could have grid views.
So for example, the bookmarks
widget lets you see a
two-column view of bookmarks.
So that's another example.
And you can actually replicate
that using a
list view as well.
And then finally, stack view,
which we'll show an
example of in a bit.
And then most of the
layout types--
as a designer, you may not be
aware of the different types--
but there are things like
relative layout, where things
are arranged relative to one
another; linear layout, where
things are arranged linearly;
and frame layout,
and things like that.
All those main ones
are supported.
So you have a lot of options in
terms of where things are
placed within the widget.
So that's one of the more open
parts of the widget system.
So those are the supported
UI elements.
Let's actually then, just jump
into examples, since I think
we're probably running
a little low on time.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah.
All right.
So we had some screenshots,
but we thought, hey, we've
actually got a device
connected.
Why don't we actually demo
these widgets live.
So we added just a few widgets
that we like to the home
screen of this device.
First of all, we've got
some news widgets.
There's the New York Times
and the BBC News widgets.
They're both resizable widgets,
both vertically scrolling.
So here you can see the
New York Times.
We've got a list of different
news articles, some headline
text, some summary text, and an
image, in most cases here
on the right.
NICK BUTCHER: Should we
demo resizing it?
ADAM KOCH: Sorry?
NICK BUTCHER: You want to show
how the resizing works?
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, you just pick
up the widget and drop it.
And then you can very easily
resize it right there.
And then the BBC News widget--
actually, what I might do is
flip this guy over here so you
can see a bit better.
This is quite a nice
widget, as well.
And when you expand it out
there, it actually grows the
columns quite nicely here.
ROMAN NURIK: This is probably
a grid view, right?
I'm guessing that's
a grid view.
NICK BUTCHER: So that's
a great example.
This is coming [INAUDIBLE]
as a grid view.
But you want your widget to
dynamically resize, based on
if I give it more horizontal
real estate, then you might
change the representation of
the story, like going into
multiple rows of a grid.
Or you might show a more
detailed headline or something
along those lines.
You want your widget to
react and make the
most of that space.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, I really
like these widgets.
Quite nice for news widgets.
And I think both of them, when
you add them, you get to
configure which category of
news that you want to
actually show here.
So you can show technology news
on your home screen if
that's what's interesting
to you.
Or you can show top news
in these cases.
So that's some news widgets.
This is the Google Play my
library widget, which is quite
nice because--
actually, how much room
do we have here?
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah,
that's fine.
ADAM KOCH: If you see that as
you resize it and let go of
the resizing handles, it re-lays
itself out, I guess
you would say.
And it's quite nice, because it
fits dynamically into all
sorts of different sizes here.
So you can have a small one if
that's what you want to use on
your home screen.
You can have it be a
wider widget here.
And it shows the various items
from your Play library.
NICK BUTCHER: It's one of my
favorite widgets, actually.
I think it's a great example
of what Roman was talking
about earlier about having
really current, really
up-to-date information.
So if you have a lot of your
information in place, if you
play music and books
and everything--
and movies-- then it will
update, so it's very easy to
get back to what you
were last doing.
So if I'm reading a book on my
phone on my commute home, and
I get home, I can just pick up
my tablet, and the widget's
updated to show that that book
is the most prominent thing in
the widget.
And I can just click it to get
straight back to where I was,
which is a brilliant
use of it, I think.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, it's
quite nice.
Over here, we've got some
miscellaneous widgets.
I've got the Songkick widget
here, which shows your plans--
upcoming concerts that
you have planned.
I've got the Google+ widget.
ROMAN NURIK: And the Google+
widget, it's not a collection
widget, but it lets you flip
between different items using
a button on screen.
So you just press this button
and flip through
the different items.
And I generally prefer the
collection-type widget, but
this is definitely another way
to focus on a single item and
actively have the user
switch between them.
ADAM KOCH: Down at the bottom,
it's the play music widget.
Uh oh.
What's going on here?
ROMAN NURIK: Which
one is that?
ADAM KOCH: That's the
Currents widget.
ROMAN NURIK: Oh, so Currents
is probably
stuck loading something.
ADAM KOCH: It's stuck
loading something.
ROMAN NURIK: Oh well.
ADAM KOCH: It's a collections
widget, again.
It's actually similar to this
YouTube widget here, where you
can flip between the
different cards.
ROMAN NURIK: And that's
an example of
a stack view widget.
So it's another type of
collection, but it's just
presented in a different way.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, the Currents
one is quite nice.
NICK BUTCHER: And you can
actually set the stack view to
auto advance, which
is kind of fun.
So if you have something like
YouTube, where it's probably
telling you about the latest
videos added to a playlist,
you can leave it there on the
home screen, and it'll
actually rotate through and
highlight that content, which
is kind of cool.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, it's
a good way to
present passive content.
So not like emails, for example,
that are obviously
very important to the user,
but featured items or
recommended items that the
user may find enjoyable.
ADAM KOCH: And then finally,
we've got a collection of
clock widgets.
And actually, the one in the
center there is DashClock
widget, built by Roman
Nurik, himself.
And it's also open source as
well, so it's actually a good
one for developers and
designers to go look
at how it was built.
ROMAN NURIK: And the way these
work, I actually just want to
point out, is that this
is an analog clock.
An analog clock, actually,
you can customize.
As a designer, you can tweak
the hour hand, the minute
hand, and basically, the system
just rotates those PNG
files to make it right.
And then here, there's something
called a text clock
that basically, you just give
it what part of the time you
want to show, and
it shows that.
And you can customize the
different topography aspects,
like font weight and things
like that, as well as
colors, and so on.
ADAM KOCH: And you can see
here, as you resize the
DashClock widget, it goes into
a sort of summary view.
And as you expand it, it
jumps back out again.
So that's it for some
of the demos, right?
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
ADAM KOCH: Should
we jump back?
Do we have any--
ROMAN NURIK: I think
that was it.
So all right, that was--
NICK BUTCHER: There's one more
thing, which I've seen a
couple of applications do, is
like we were saying earlier, a
home screen widget is prime,
prime real estate on the
user's home screen.
And the fact that they've put
you on the home screen means
they're probably quite engaged
with your product.
So I think it's actually an
opportunity to use them quite
intelligently.
So yes, you can highlight the
newest, latest information.
But one interesting example I've
seen is a shopping app
where if you've abandoned the
shopping cart, it has a widget
showing you the latest offers
or whatever it is
targeted to the user.
But it will actually insert a
little item at the top saying,
why don't you finish
your journey?
And so, and so forth.
So remember that they're small
versions of your app, almost,
not just a way to highlight
your interesting content.
So think about interesting ways
that you can use your
home screen widgets.
ROMAN NURIK: Absolutely.
Also, we should probably
mention there's some
categories.
If you're building an app in a
certain category, you pretty
much have to build a widget,
or else your users will
comment, like, where's
your widget?
A couple of examples, if you're
building a sports app,
you should probably have a
scores widget for your league
or for whatever information
you have.
If you're building
a music, app--
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, a music
app, gotta have one.
ROMAN NURIK: --absolutely
have transport controls.
So yeah, definitely
build a widget.
All right.
Well, with that, thanks
for joining.
A couple of announcements
before we sign off.
So as we mentioned a few weeks
ago on the show, the "Android
Design in Action" show and the
"App Clinic" show, we're
actually starting to integrate
a little better.
So when we do a topic on
Tuesday, the folks over in
Mountain View, California, will
be doing the same topic,
the same general category
on Friday.
So tune in this Friday to "The
App Clinic" to check out their
thoughts on home
screen widgets.
All right, with that, I'm
your host, Roman Nurik.
ADAM KOCH: See you guys.
Adam Koch.
NICK BUTCHER: Bye from
Nick Butcher.
ROMAN NURIK: All right.
See you guys next week.